all right well uh welcome back of course
to our special finland show now it's
clear by this point that i've achieved
some level of popularity in finland but
i knew i'd really made it when i was
invited to appear on some of finland's
hottest talk shows
take a look
we will
so what show was that i just did that
good morning that was good morning the
next one is wonderful morning wonderful
morning yes so there's good morning and
then wonderful morning
[Music]
is
it was great to have you here thank you
very much
[Applause]
so it's three shows
[Music]
welcome conan o'brien everyone settle
down
cool down yeah yeah so you've been here
less than 30 hours yes i believe
thanks for having me see you later
goodbye everybody
[Music]
incredible
oh
thank you
it's gonna go well
when you grow up
[Laughter]
do you have to be a funny looking old
man to get a talk show in america
it helps
it helps there are some attractive
looking people but they don't use them
for the comedy shows
uh but yes i'm 62 years old
very strange looking man and it's helped
me a lot
in america
you have said you are
like a
god in finland i did say i was a god in
finland and maybe i got a little crazy
in the head
i'm probably not a god here but let's
face it big star in my country and i
came to finland and i thought i'd be a
big deal here clearly as we can see
uh
that's not the
case but uh by the way your show has all
the charm of the nuremberg trial
i hope you get as many laughs
what's that no someone's kicking stuff
randomly this is a nightmare
are you two friends are you related
are you too related no no you're not
related you're just you both went to
school and we're both wearing dressed as
young gangsters three piece suits and
decided let's be friends
pretty much what
you are afraid of being naked did you
ever take a shower after team class
uh no no i've never been naked around
other people and that's including my
wife
you are proud to look like daddy
halloween yes do you really think
it is cool to be a man who looks like a
woman
thank you nice meeting you bro
oh right and then
nice is that what you do that's the you
do that that's
it's going to go far
19 will be beaten
[Applause]
[Music]
my life here in finland keeps getting
more and more exciting
i'm at the pelvis awards right now it's
the finished version of the emmys and
i'm being given a special award
for the most surprising tv personality
in
[Applause]
over finland
thank you
thank you very much
uh first of all i'd like to uh thank you
for this award for looking like your
president thank you very much
i accept this award on behalf of
everyone on late night with conan
o'brien and i thank you from the from
the bottom of my heart from your
president to the people in the street
you're some of the nicest people that
i've ever met and i thank you very much
we're proud to be on in this country
thank you
[Applause]
you